This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The story goes like this. And keep in mind with all these origin stories, when they sound a little too much like stories, they're probably not completely true, but anyway. The story goes like this. The Ophilis van Canal hated Shivori. There was nothing he despised more than trying to walk in or out of a building and locking horns with some other man in a game of, no you for, no of course you for, no I insist you for, and more than that socially mandated deference to other men, the off-less van canal hated opening doors for women.
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。故事是这样的。请记住，所有这些起源故事，当它们听起来太像故事时，可能并不完全真实，但不管怎样。故事是这样的。Theophil Van Kannel讨厌希沃里。没有什么比试图走进或走出建筑时与另一个人狭路相逢更让他鄙视的了，那种“不，您先请”、“不，当然您先请”、“不，我坚持您先请”的游戏，更不用说这种社会强加的对其他男人的顺从了，这位Van Kannel先生尤其讨厌为女性开门。
And so the off-less van canal, or Theo for short, took a German innovation from 1881, the Tuha-Onel-Ufzuk, or door without draft of air. He made some improvements to the design and in 1888 was awarded an American patent for the improved revolving door. The first one was installed in Times Square in 1899. That's our producer Sam Greenspin. Van Cannell's improved revolving door had three compartments and weather stripping to ensure an energy efficient fit inside the door frame.
因此，Van Kannel（简称西奥）采用了1881年的一项德国创新，即“无气流门”（Thür-ohne-Luftzug）。他对设计进行了一些改进，并于1888年获得了改进型旋转门的美国专利。第一扇旋转门于1899年在时代广场安装。这是我们的制作人萨姆·格林斯潘。Van Kannel改进的旋转门有三个隔间和挡风条，以确保门框内具有节能效果。
His 1888 patent states that quote, it is perfectly noiseless in its operation and effectively prevents the entrance of wind, snow, rain, or dust, either when it is closed or when persons are passing through it. And as a bonus, annihilates any chance of social interaction that one might have while entering or exiting a building.
他在1888年的专利中指出：“它在运行中完全无声，并有效地防止风、雪、雨或灰尘进入，无论是在关闭状态还是在人们通过时。”作为附加好处，它消除了人们在进出建筑时可能发生的任何社交互动机会。
The motto of Theo Van Cannell's revolving door company was always open, always closed. And so for the past hundred plus years, we have had the solution to keep dust and noise and rain and sleet and snow from entering our buildings. And yet, the likelihood that you will actually use it is very, very low. The problem is that people don't use revolving doors because they're heavy or they feel like they might get stuck in them. Compartment terrify people.
西奥·Van Kannel旋转门公司的座右铭是：永远开放，永远关闭。因此，在过去的一百多年里，我们有了阻止灰尘、噪音、雨水、雨夹雪和雪进入建筑的解决方案。然而，你实际去使用它的可能性非常非常低。问题在于人们不使用旋转门，因为它们很重，或者他们觉得可能会被卡在里面。隔间让人感到恐惧。
And this shouldn't be a big surprise. When you're approaching a revolving door, it's always hard to tell how hard you're gonna have to push it to get a going. And if it is already moving, gonna have to push it to get a going and if it is already moving You have to time it just right and there's also the anxiety of getting a limb caught or maybe your bag And if oh man if you're walking with someone and talking to them And it's a little bit bigger of a revolving door and you accidentally get in there with them and then you're with them
这不应该让人感到意外。当你走近一扇旋转门时，很难判断你得用多大劲才能推开它。如果它已经在转动了，你必须把握好时机。此外，还有肢体或包被夹住的焦虑。如果……天哪，如果你和某人一起走边聊，而这是一个稍微大一点的旋转门，你不小心和他们一起进去了，然后你们挨得那么近，甚至只是那几秒钟，这也让人……是的，深呼吸。深呼吸。噢。如果你读过阿兰·摩尔的《守望者》，你可能还记得这样一个细节：一些超级英雄对披风心存戒惕，因为有一次他们的披风斗士同伴，
like really close even for that few seconds and it's just Yeah deep breaths. Deep breaths. Ooh. And if you've read Alan Moore's Watchman, you may remember that detail about how some of the superheroes are wary of capes because one time their caped crusader colleague,
“美元比尔”的披风被旋转门夹住了，因此当抢劫犯靠近并近距离头部开枪时，他动弹不得。只要你能看出你是需要推还是拉来开门——这个话题本身就可以做成一整集——平开门就是很简单。而且我们大多数人，不像Van Kannel，都是适应良好的正常人，确实会试图为彼此开门。每当有一群人一起走，队伍里第一个人打开平开门时，
Dollar Bill, got his cape caught in a revolving door and was thus immobilized as a bank robber approached him and shot him in the head point blank. As long as you can tell if you need to push or pull to open the door, and that subject could be a whole episode and of itself, swing indoors are just easy. And most of us, unlike Van Canal, are well-adjusted human beings who actually do try to open the door for each other. Anytime you have a stream of people walking together and the first person in that line opens the swing door,
其余的人往往会跟着走。所以这位是安德鲁·谢伊。我叫安德鲁·谢伊。我是纽约市的一名平面设计师、作家和教育工作者。安德鲁对旋转门的痴迷始于他读研究生的时候。当时我正在做关于社会变革设计的毕业论文，我的一位好朋友来拜访我。他发现我在做什么，便指着旋转门说，
the rest tend to follow. So this is Andrew Shea. My name is Andrew Shea. I'm a graphic designer, writer, and educator in New York City. Andrew's obsession with revolving doors started when he was in graduate school. I was doing my thesis on designing for social change, and a good friend of mine was visiting. He found out what I was doing, and he pointed to the revolving doors, and he's like,
如果我想为社会变革设计点什么，我希望他能让人更多地使用旋转门。这是他对我的挑战。安德鲁深入研究了关于旋转门的文献，令人震惊的是，这些文献少得可怜。但他确实偶遇了一项研究。一项由麻省理工学院学生做的研究。我想他们是在城市规划系，但它是围绕可持续性展开的，
if he wanted to design for social change, I wish he would get people to use revolving doors more often. That was his challenge to me. Andrew dove into the literature on revolving doors, which was shockingly quite slim. But he did come across a study. A study done by some MIT students. I think they were in the urban planning department, but it was focused on sustainability,
这是我能找到的唯一似乎对旋转门及其影响有详尽信息的资源。里面包含了很多数学内容。我有点避开数学，因为我不知道该如何解释它。但你其实不需要看懂数学就能理解其中的逻辑。旋转门之所以能节能，其基本原理是旋转门从不打开。它们可以防止室内外空气的自由流通。
and it was the only resource I could find out there that seemed to have a thorough tate of information about revolving doors and their impact. And I had a lot of math in it. I kind of avoided the math because I didn't know how to interpret it. But you don't really need to see the math to understand the logic. The basic idea of how a revolving door saves energy is that revolving doors never open. They can prevent the free exchange of air from the outside to the inside.
当人们穿过旋转门时，他们并没有把门打开。泄漏进来的空气只有两部分：一部分是随着人们和旋转门隔间一起被运送过来的空气，另一部分是从挡风条周围泄漏出来的空气。那是丹·瓦索洛夫斯基。说得对。丹是旋转门研究的作者之一。早在他在麻省理工学院读研究生时，他就参与了一个项目，研究人们对旋转门的行为习惯以及使用旋转门所能带来的节能效果。
As the people move through the revolving door, they don't open it. The only air that leaks through is either the actual air that's being transported over the people and the chambers of the revolving door, or whatever leaks around the weather stripping. That's Dan Wasalowski. Shoddy. Dan was one of the authors on the revolving door or whatever leaks around the weather stripping. That's Dan Wasolowski. Shoddy. Dan was one of the authors on the revolving door study. Back when he was a grad student at MIT, he worked on a project studying people's behavior with respect to revolving doors and the energy savings associated with using revolving doors
在大型建筑中。在某种程度上，这是一项不会放过他的研究。我们并不是第一个联系他采访此事的人。我不理解。你知道的，我在材料科学和工程领域大约有20篇同行评议的出版物。而我为什么总是被追问这篇八年前写的学期论文？不管怎样，丹做了一堆听起来像这样的科学研究。与该材料中所有水蒸气相关潜热。我们没有给你提供足够的背景让你完全听懂，但结果是这样的：
in large buildings. And in some ways, it's a study that will not leave him alone. We were not the first people to contact him for an interview about this. I don't understand it. You know, I've got like 20 peer reviewed publications and material science and engineering. And what do I have like constant contact about it? A term paper I did eight years ago. Anyway, Dan did a bunch of science that sounds like this. Leighton heat associated with all the water vapor that is in that material. We didn't really give you enough context to understand that a little bit, but here's the
使用平开门交换的空气量是使用旋转门时的八倍。或者换句话说，旋转门交换的空气量比平开门少八倍。再次由纽约的设计师安德鲁·谢伊讲述，这一事实深深引起了他的共鸣。这完全讲得通，因为打开一扇平开门就像在建筑上撕开一个洞。所有这些热气或冷气都泄漏出去了，建筑不得不全速运转来弥补温度和湿度的波动。丹·瓦索洛夫斯基和他的团队观察了麻省理工学院校园里的一栋既有旋转门又有平开门的建筑，发现旋转门的使用率大约为25%。
result. There's eight times more air exchanged when you use the swing door than when you use the revolving door. Or put another way. Revolving door is exchanged eight times less air than swinging doors. That's Andrew Shea again, the designer in New York, and this factoid really resonated with him. Which makes total sense, because opening a swinging door is like tearing a hole in a York. And this factoid really resonated with him. Which makes total sense because opening a swinging door is like daring a hole in a building. All that heat or air conditioning leaks out and the building has to kick in the high gear to make up for the temperature and humidity fluctuation. Dan Wasolowski and his team observed a building on the MIT campus that had both revolving doors and swinging doors, and found that the revolving door usage sat at about 25%.
该团队意识到，除了节约能源和保护环境之外，如果每个人都只使用这栋建筑中的旋转门，他们每年还能为麻省理工学院节省超过7500美元。他们发现，只需通过一些简单的标牌，就能将该建筑的旋转门使用率提高到60%或70%。尽管麻省理工学院的研究是在波士顿进行的，而安德鲁在纽约，但这似乎是一个非常通用的数据集。于是这一切激励了纽约市的安德鲁·谢伊。
The team realized that in addition to conserving energy and helping the environment, they could also save MIT more than $7,500 annually if everyone just used the revolving door in this one building. And they found they could raise revolving door usage at that building to 60 or 70% with just some simple signage. And even though the MIT study was done in Boston and Andrew was in New York, it seemed like a pretty transposable data set. So all this inspired Andrew Shay in New York City.
他决定接受他朋友在读研究生时的挑战，看看一些简单的观察和标牌能为纽约的一栋建筑带来什么改变。那栋建筑在哥伦比亚大学。那是应用科学大楼，是一栋崭新的建筑。这栋建筑的同一个入口处有三组平开门和三组旋转门。
He decided to take up his friend's challenge back from when he was in grad school and see what some simple observation and signage could do for one building in New York. That building was at Columbia University. It was the applied sciences building, it's a brand new building. There's three sets of swinging doors and three sets of revolving doors at the one entry point of this building.
安德鲁开始只是观察这栋建筑。我大概花总共两个月的时间，每周一次，我想那是周二早晨。其中有些星期我一周去两次，周二和周四。我观察人们进出建筑并统计人数。他在两个月期间统计了大约20个小时。我发现只有28%的人在使用旋转门。
Andrew started by just watching the building. I spent probably altogether about two months, once a week, I think it was Tuesday mornings. Some of those weeks I was there for twice a week, Tuesdays and Thursdays. I watched people exiting and entering the building and counted the number of people. And he counted for about 20 hours in a two month period. I discovered that only 28% of people were using the revolving doors.
所以我的第一次干预只是制作了一个非常基础的标牌。我拿了一张8.5x11英寸的纸。非常简单地写着：请使用旋转门。他添加了关于旋转门交换的空气量比平开门少八倍的事实。它被粗糙地贴在平开门上。这使得58%的人随后开始使用旋转门。这是一个30个百分点的增长。这是一个30%的增长，是的。当然，我想知道如何能让这个数字变得更高。安德鲁制作了第二个箭头形状的标牌。这个箭头比第一个标牌小。但随后旋转门的使用率实际上比上一次尝试下降了五个百分点，降至53%。于是安德鲁进行了调整，把它做大了，并让它符合哥伦比亚大学的
So my first intervention was just to create a very basic sign. I took an eight and a half by eleven piece of paper. I wrote, really simply, please use revolving doors. He added that fact to it about revolving doors exchanging eight times less air than swinging doors. It was very crudely taped onto the swinging door. It caused 58% of people to then go ahead and use revolving doors. So that's a 30 point increase. It was a 30% increase, yep. And of course, I wanted to know how I could get that number even higher. Andrew made a second sign in the shape of an arrow. And this arrow was smaller than the first sign. But then revolving door usage actually fell five points from his previous attempt to 53%. So Andrew tweaked it, made it larger, and he also made it match Columbia University's
视觉形象。哥伦比亚大学的品牌系统中有一套浅蓝色和深蓝色的色调。所以我的希望是，品牌标志能帮助人们更多地与之产生共鸣，并更加认真地对待它。事实上，最终有71%的人因此使用了旋转门。71%，比他刚开始时的28%上升了43个百分点。这里是99pi总部，我们很好奇这是否也能在湾区发生。于是我和我们的实习生艾瑞芙·特鲁夫曼一起去奥克兰市中心踩点了一栋建筑。
visual identity. Columbia has like a light blue and a dark blue color palette in their branding system. So my hope was that the branding would help people connect with it more and take it more seriously. And in fact, 71% of people ended up using the revolving doors as a result of that. 71% that's up 43 points from where he started at 28%. Here at 99pi HQ, we were curious to find out if that could happen here in the Bay Area. So I went with our intern, Avery Truffleman, to go stake out a building in downtown Oakland.
这是艾瑞芙和萨姆在观察阶段。我体内残留的科学家部分必须在这里提醒大家，我们今天讨论的所有数据集都非常小，请理解这一点。但大家的观察结果是一致的。如果有得选择，旋转门就是没那么受欢迎。所以我们的实验已经进行两分钟了，情况怎么样？我们有12个走平开门的，0个走旋转门的。最好说根本没人用旋转门。
This is Avery and Sam in the observation stage. The vestigial scientist part of me has to remind you here that all the data sets we're talking about today are very small, so understand that. But everyone's observations are aligned. Given the choice, revolving doors just aren't that popular. So it's been two minutes in our experiment so far, how are we doing? We've got 12 for swinging 0 for revolving. It's best to say nobody is using their revolving doors.
而当有人使用旋转门时，这就很引人注目了。好的，记1个旋转门。哇，真是个迷人的人。我觉得这不太正常。哦，等等。半小时后，他们统计了结果。对，统计出来了。我们做得怎么样？259人使用了平开门。
And when someone did use a revolving door, it was notable. Okay, market 1 revolving door. Wow, what a charm. I don't think it's normal. Oh my wait. After a half hour they tallied up the results. Right, tallied up. How do we do? 259 people use swinging doors.
在30分钟内有4个人使用了旋转门。好的，所以……所以，是的，让我们把这些标牌打印出来。这些是安德鲁·谢伊设计的标牌。这是一个箭头，上面写着：请使用旋转门。它们的换气量少八倍。你知道的，刚好有人在用旋转门，我们在哪里……好啦，所有的标牌都挂出去了。
Four people use revolving doors in a 30 minute period. Okay, so... So, yeah, let's type up these signs. These are the signs designed by Andrew Shea. It's an arrow that says, please use revolving door. They exchange eight times less air. You know, just the people are using the revolving doors where we're exactly. Alright, all the signs are out.
好的，让我们看看会发生什么。那个贴在侧边。并使用了旋转门。接着是另一个人。接着又是另一个人使用了旋转门。这位女士甚至在等旋转门转完，以便她进去并朝另一个方向走去。他们已经在增加旋转门的交通
Alright, let's see what happens. That one's on the side. And uses the revolving door. Followed by another guy. Followed by another guy using the revolving door. This lady is even waiting for the revolving door to finish so she can get in and go the other direction. They're already increasing the revolving door traffic
流量了。不到五分钟就翻倍了。又过了30分钟，99PI团队统计了结果。1个旋转门。4，3，2，3。好的。好的。
flow. It doubled in less than five minutes. And after another 30 minutes, team 99 PI tell you the results. One for revolving. Four, three, two, three. All right. All right.
我们做得怎么样？好的。好的。所以这些是使用平开门的人，尽管标牌就贴在上面。5，10，15，20，25，30，35，40，40，40，40，40，45，150，155，157。然后这次使用旋转门的人是5，10，15，20，20，65，69。因此，在没有标牌的情况下，这栋建筑在周一中午12点30分到1点之间，最初只有1.5%。有了标牌之后……
How we do? OK. OK. So these are people who use the swinging doors, even though the sign was on them. 5, 10, 15, 20, 25, 30, 35, 40, 40, 40, 40, 40, 45, 150, 155, 157. And then people who use the revolving doors this time are 5, 10, 15, 20, 20, 65, 69. So with no sign, this building between the hours of 12, 30 and 1 on a Monday, originally it was 1.5 percent. After the sign...
有30.5%的人通过旋转门，而没有标牌时只有1.5%。所以，还算不错，是的。现在我们没有测试所有的变体，人们可能按照预期理解了标牌，接收到了旋转门更节能的信息，并据此调整了他们的行为。或者他们可能只是以为平开门坏了，或者他们只是注意到有什么不同寻常的地方，从而促使他们使用了旋转门。
30 and a half percent of people went through the revolving doors when there was a sign pointing to them as opposed to 1.5 percent without the signs. So, not too shabby, yeah. Now we did not try testing all the variations, so people could have interpreted the signs as intended, taking in the message that revolving doors were more energy efficient, and adjusted their behavior accordingly. Or they could have just thought the swinging door was out of order, or they could have just noticed something was out of the ordinary, and it nudged them into using the revolving door.
不管发生了什么，有一点是显而易见的：在门上贴个箭头能让人做出行动，如果你想让人使用旋转门，这是一个很好的起点。说完这些，萨姆和艾瑞芙离开了那栋建筑的大厅，把标牌摘了下来。就像安德鲁·谢伊在哥伦比亚大学摘下标牌并与当权者分享他的研究结果一样，但最终什么也没有改变。丹·瓦索洛夫斯基说，麻省理工学院最终确实将他研究的一些基本概念纳入其中，当时他们制作了节能贴纸贴在外门上，尽管他认为自己的标牌更好。
Whatever happened, this much is clear. Putting up an arrow on a door makes people do things, and if you want to get people to use a revolving door, that's a good place to start. And with that, Sam and Avery left the lobby of that building and took down the science. Just like Andrew Shea took down his science at Columbia and shared his results with the powers that be, but nothing ever came of it. Dan Wasolowski says that MIT did eventually incorporate some of the basic concepts of his study when they created sustainability stickers to place on their outer doors, although he thought his signs were better.
但提高旋转门使用率的另一个真正强有力的方法是从建筑本身解决这个问题。事实证明，实际上还有更高效的旋转门，比如奥克兰的万豪酒店。事实证明，实际上还有更高效的旋转门，比如奥克兰的万豪酒店。它大得多，是入口的视觉焦点，并且有三个隔板，大到你和一个陌生人待在其中一个里面也不会觉得太奇怪。
But another really powerful way to increase the use of revolving doors is to address the issue in the architecture itself. It turns out there are actually much more effective revolving doors out there, like at the Marietta Hotel in Oakland. It turns out there are actually much more effective revolving doors out there, like at the Mariette Hotel in Oakland. It's much larger, it's the visual focus of the entrance, and it has three dividers which are actually big enough for you to be inside one of them with the stranger, and not feel too weird about it.
而且它们是自动旋转的。也许最重要的是，如果门童没有看到你正走向平开门，他们不会为你打开它们。因此，如果你无法获得机构支持，或者无法买到一个全新的巨大旋转门，安德鲁·谢伊有一个旋转门行动包，你可以免费下载。带到你当地的办公楼去。不包含透明胶带。顺便说一句。仅供参考。因人而异。我懂。回头见。
And they revolve automatically. And perhaps most importantly, the dormant won't open the swinging doors for you unless they see you're already going for them. So if you can't get institutional buy-inin or get a brand new gigantic revolving door, Andrew Shea has a revolving door action kit that you can download for free. Take to your local office building. Scotch tape not included. It's B-Y-O-S-T. FYI. Y-M-M-V. I see Y-V. BRB.
噢，我的天哪。《99%隐形》本周由萨姆·格林斯潘、艾瑞芙·特鲁夫曼和我罗曼·马尔斯制作。我们是91.7号项目，旧金山本地公共广播电台KW和旧金山美国建筑师学会的项目。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞本节目，我们所有人都在Twitter、Instagram和Spotify上，但要了解关于这个故事的更多信息，
Oh, MGA. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Sam Greenspan, Avery, Truffleman, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7. Local Public Radio K-W and San Francisco in the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook, all of us are on Twitter, Instagram, and Spotify, but to find out more about this story,
包括酷炫的图片和链接，并收听《99%隐形》的所有单集，你必须访问 99ipi.org。[♪ 铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声，铃声。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。
including cool pictures and links, and listen to all the episodes of 99% Invisible. You must go to 99ipi.org. [♪ BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, BELL, BELL RINGING, BELL RINGING, There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。